nine months after they started
construction the Big Bend crane raises
the first of four segments to close the
center span since this is the last
segment we're left with a seven foot
closure so it's a very very tight space
we have to operate we will literally
only have inches there that are
available for us to bring that segment
up and clear everything that's in the
way
we're seen history being made right now
a tragedy is kind of coming to the
of the rebuilding
it is exciting to see the last piece
going and contrasting this with when the
bridge came down in the horror of all
the concrete in the water and how
quickly it's changed from
the last pieces of this
bring add the last piece of the span is
ratcheted into place
the entire 504 foot span all 120
segments were erected in just 47 days
each one of the segments is a little
different we often think about them as
children each one was born on a specific
day and goes through a period of
maturity to see the last ones coming up
and getting into place it makes it seem
almost like you're your son or daughter
has gone off to college it's that last
goodbye before they where they go off on
their own life
feels really good you know don't worry
that we're gonna be being able to put
this bridge up and get people across
this river you know we're finally
getting the lives of this area back
together and a little normalcy back it's
kind of like an honor to to actually
kind of be working on this and be able
to tell my kids down the road that I had
a part in building a bridge it's gonna
be run for over hundred years so